اذا في اليوم ال
81 تتسارع التطورات في قطاع غزه شمالا
وجنوبا وحتى في الوسط اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي قبل قليل عن بدء البدء الفعلي
لتوسيع العمليه في وسط القطاع ولكن سنبدا
مما يجري في الشمال شمال قطاع غزه والسبب
الذي نبدا منه هو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كان
توغل الى هذه المناطق في الايام الاولى
للحرب على قطاع غزه ولكن وبعد مرور
881 يوما لهذا التوغل لا يزال الجيش غير
قادر على السيطره على كل المناطق التي
يقاتل فيها بمعنى اخر اليوم شهدنا قتالا
في مناطق كان قد قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
قد سيطر عليها بالكامل في جباليا البلد
شهدت اشتباكات في الشجاعيه ما زالت هناك
اشتباكات جاريه رغم ان اسرائيل اعلنت قبل
اقل من نصف ساعه انها اعادت السيطره على
هذه المنطقه لكن من الواضح ان هناك جيوب
مقاومه بل مقاومه عنيف الجيش الاسرائيلي
وصف اليوم في بيان له القتال في شمال
القطاع بانه قتال على شاكله حرب العصابات
تكثر فيه الكمائن واغلب الخسائر التي
توقعها كتائب القسام وفصائل المقاومه
بالجيش الاسرائيلي تنتج عن كمائن ينصبونها
سواء في الاحياء التي يقاتلون فيها او
سواء باستدراج اليات الى حقول الغام بينما
هذه التطورات تجري في القطاع والاشتباكات
التي ما زالت مستمره في جنوب القطاع اليوم
تركز القصف الاسرائيلي العنيف بل العنيف
جدا على اكثر من منطقه اغارت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه على النصير وعلى مخيم البريج
جنوب مدينه غزه اما منطقه جحر ديك منطقه
جحره ديك كما نذكر بانها من اولى المناطق
التي توغل
اليها جيش الاحتلال عند بدء العمليه
العسكريه جحر الديك
هي يعني شرق قطاع غزه وكانت تسمى خاصره
رخوه لانها لا يوجد فيها ادنيه لا يوجد
هناك مكان للمقاتل ان يختبئ ومن هناك كانت
سهوله التوغل الاسرائيلي اليوم هناك
عده تطورات في جحر الديق كتائب القسام
فجرت فتحه نفق بمجموعه اسرائيليه وقتلت
عددا من الجنود وهناك اشتباكات ايضا
الجديد ان الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي يتحدث
منذ الصباح عن انه سيوسع العمليه العسكريه
في وسط القطاع بدا هجوما فعليا على مخيم
البريج مخيم البريج في الوسط اليوم الامم
المتحده حذرت من ان اسرائيل اصلا طلبت من
سكان قطاع من سكان المناطق غزه والمناطق
الشماليه التوجه الى المناطق الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه ولكنها تستهدف هذه المناطق في
هذا القصف
اليوم المشهد في الجنوب لا يقل سخونه عن
باقي المناطق بل وربما قد يكون الاسخن
خاصه مع و معلومات ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
دفع
بقوات مؤله تزيد على
10050 اليه تتمركز في مناطق عده جنوب قطاع
غزه في المناطق التي تقول اسرائيل انها
تسيطر عليها بالكامل في بني سهيلا وعبس
والزن ولكن في هذه الاثناء القتال في
خانيونس لا يتوقف خان يونس هي المعركه
الاساسيه والكبيره التي تج جري جنوب
القطاع الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انها معقل
حركه حماس والحقيقه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
لم يتوكل حتى الان من تطويق كامل المدينه
هناك قتال شرس تصفه اسرائيل بانه الاعنف
ربما او الاكثر ضراوه لنكون دقيقين في
مجمل العمليات التي جرت وتجري الان في
قطاع غزه طبعا ايضا هناك عمليات
عسكريه من كتائب بالقسام وسرايا القدس على
هذه الوحدات المتوغلة
نحر الديك وقالت ايضا انها لن تسمح بعد
الان بان تبقى
غزه منصه لاطلاق الصواريخ فاطلقت القسام
وسرايا القدس مجموعه من الصواريخ استهدفت
مناطق واسعه في غلاف غزه في سديروت في
كفار عزه وفي ايضا ساعد لماذا ذكرنا ساعد
وهي قريبه من كفر عزه اهميه ساعد انها
ليست فقط تجمعا سكانيا هي تجمع صناعي فيها
بعض الصناعات الاساسيه التي تخدم
منطقه غلاف غزه